welcome back everybody I'm sitting here
with a hilarious dan Telfer who just
killed thank you so much yeah this is
this is the cue card they had don't
forget first a welcome back and now
we're in this part so we can we can
really do whatever we want you I like
your jacket I like what you're wearing
right look at this it's got little smoky
pipes in there adorable absolutely we
don't have the insurance money to
protect you
we're a small show fowling you fall no
problem here we just leave you play a
bunch of little kids instruments oh yeah
they just dance over you're everybody's
fine they slow jam your recovery I was
watching The Hobbit last night no foolin
I haven't seen the second one yet which
I'm kind of upset about but have two
kids so like my ability to go see whimsy
whenever I want is its limited to home
you know I understand let me warn ya spy
toes I think they should tell you Harry
Potter desolation of smaug anytime
there's like huge spiders give me a
heads-up I just want to mentally prepare
this is no bit I'm watching it last
night I was like oh I'm glad this is
what I'm seeing right before slumber
well at Peter Jackson like but wait
Peter Jackson makes monsters too is like
the bottom of your nightmares like just
like the absolute pit of your stomach
terrifying like in the Lord of the Rings
movie with she lobe like she lobes face
look like the naked woman from The
Shining like yes like the pull yep like
desiccated corpse of a tragically
murdered woman don't like it no or not
that scary like the dragon like oh no
look out Bilbo I haven't seen it yet but
I heard they just cast Benedict
Cumberbatch in he's kind of nice right
so probably just like a dude hanging out
it's like love Benny come bees
but dragons a little too chatty to be
scary
look out he's got anecdotes that go
nowhere